the first person to go on trial on
charges from the assault on the capitol
has been convicted on all counts it was
a pivotal victory for the justice
department because it could create a
blueprint for trying hundreds of cases
like it scott mcfarland has reaction to
the verdict in the trial where
prosecutors had almost all of the
evidence on their side
it took the jury less than four hours to
convict guy refered to texas on five
counts including carrying a gun to the
capitol grounds obstruction of congress
and interfering with police he now
potentially faces up to 60 years in
prison
for days prosecutors showed jurors a
series of videos and photos of revit at
the front of the mob on january 6 2021
though he never made it inside the
capitol
his own son testified against refit
saying he was so frightened by his
father's anti-government rhetoric that
he tipped off the fbi and he pointed to
messages in which refit bragged after
the riot i felt so
patriotic and felt like such an american
girl we did
refit didn't testify and his lawyers
didn't present any witnesses one juror
spoke with us after the verdict asking
we not reveal her identity did that
matter to you at all that this man
didn't take the stand and didn't present
a defense
it did it did
the one time that we saw any emotion out
of him was when his son took the stand
so yeah it did it mattered a lot
prosecutors didn't just win this case
they potentially won new leverage over
those still awaiting trial
there will be many defendants who've
seen this verdict
saw how it was returned quickly
unanimously the strength of the
government's case and they're going to
seek a plea deal and they're going to
seek cooperation as part of that after
the verdict refit's wife told me she
hopes other defendants are not scared
into taking pleas
the reason that we have all guilty
verdicts is they are making a point out
of guy
there's also a new high profile january
6 defendant proud boys leader enrique
tario was arrested on tuesday and
appeared in a miami court charged with
conspiracy he didn't take part in the
riot but prosecutors say he helped plan
and direct the mob
tario's attorney tells me they have no
comment but are back in court friday as
for guy refit his wife says they plan to
appeal this verdict but sentencing in
the meantime is set for june 8.
nate
scott thank you